[Music]
When you simply do something else. If, for example, you know your efforts now
, even in the case of photographers, you are
entering 02.
I think it's different
from 'Kim Ki-ho'
And what
I'm doing is working with gold leaf.
After about 1856,
my father and I are now designated as national intangible cultural assets.
It can be said that it is a characteristic outside of the Korean palace.
This was not made for the nobles, and it was used only for the royal family's first costume so that it could be used environmentally only in the
royal family.
Then, now, at the work university that makes the design, the pattern is yen, and
then you take the you who made the sale, and if you
unwrap it and make it, then you put it on the carved plate, and then you cut it with
the glue, and before the reincarnation is hardened,
the gold leaf is now made there.  The superb view doesn't make gold leaf, but I took the
gold leaf made elsewhere, and now it's the work of kneading it with my fingers
and sticking it.
And my father is now dead is the 1st of the day.
Among the photos of my father, I wrote this time as a
portrait of
him, and now he
is looking at me like this in the back.  Meaning I now think of it.
Each problem has two meanings, one is  Now, this
is a culture that has been passed down to our family.
It is a lifestyle. So, continuing that
means that we are continuing the culture in our house now. And now our fingerprints.
Those people in our house are coming out, me, now, the staff, and
teaching our local church, I want our children
to do it right now, but while I’m still making a decision, I can’t say anything right now.